since gm ocean stone
yeah i've never played with increment
one bunch of bits i think
[Music]
okay let's play a bit small state in
this round
go e4
let's go e4 e5 knight f3
bishop d5 spanish let's see
what mountain does
yeah i was going to say i hope he plays
i hope he plays bishop on this i just
don't know the other lines much
look at how strong it is d4
d5 bishop e6 is the main line
then there is like there are a lot of
moves knight d2 c3 queen e2
i don't really know the theory
i really don't know at least i don't
remember
i just trying to it's trying to recall
something
okay this is one attention
knight takes c5 was also an option
also quite interesting queen e2 now the
idea is to go group d1 and c4
it's one of the links i just know that
much
i just know that this is nothing else so
we'll see
it bishops the file now we obviously got
the video
yeah i don't know what to play knight
bd2 makes sense and bishop e3 makes
sense system
i sort of like bishop e3
just trade these bishops and go with the
one
yeah i think this makes a lot of sense
yeah castles i'm just going to go to d1
and
and just take it from there i don't know
it's not so easy for black to play if
you're because
when you move the queen the d5 pawn is
ringing and
after the d5 pawn is lost the e4 knot
quite tricky for black i think
now i don't know what my threat is
somehow like i just don't see a concrete
batman
i think i can just play position with
knight c3
or knight d2
the black knight on c6 just
makes it a bit harder for black to
defend d5 and
that's why he moves the knight away from
c6 so that
he can play pawn to c6 to protect d5
so now i think i should go knight c3 or
knight d2
probably to d2 because
after knight f5 i can just go queen f4
and
not double my pawns
my d2 take with the look
c6 okay
maybe c3
would like to put my knight on c5 but
that's a bit obvious
i think i'll again c3 is just to play
bishop c2 now
the bishop is on a good diagram bishop
is happy
and yeah
just thinking what to do
i see one idea i don't know how it is
objectively but it looks nice
knight d4 and c4 i'm going to do a queen
d3
surprisingly hard to meet for luck but i
think black has to go g6
because otherwise the bishop on e6 is
just hanging
okay i think he smells something
yeah i was hoping that he would go c5
plus but even that i'm not sure how bad
it is
okay now i have a lot of nice looking
options again e6 is one
knight b3 is another just position
i don't want to play position
[Music]
for some reason
okay let's play queen d3 this is of
course the other moon
always nice to threaten a mate in one
move in g6 i'm just going to come back
to e3 and
threaten h6 don't know why i did this
exactly
just
definitely going c5 at some point
and i think he just has to
all right i don't see how you can do
without c5 here and
i just want to go knight f3 and try to
get my queen to h6
so plan is quite simple
rookie 8
has to be some way too has to be some
way to finish the game
i just don't see it queen h6 seems good
enough to me
see if i knight a free knight g4 okay
this is
definitely once just has to be
it just absolutely has to be with us
something is going to come on the third
rank some rook is going to cover the
third question
and knight is
look d3 or rook e3 probably with d3
f4 just take this one
okay
[Music]
that was nice that was a good game
okay